check out Matt Lauer and his ex-wife and
that rope all smiles together they were
supporting their daughter Romi at the
Hamptons classic horse show it's the
first time the pair has been snapped
together since finalizing their divorce
last month on July 10th et confirmed
that Annette had filed for divorce et
had also learned that Matt had agreed to
pay a net
20 million dollars in the divorce
settlement ahead of the news a source
told ET quote they both wanted to settle
their divorce amicably for their
children's sake but it hasn't been easy
we wish nothing but the best for for him
and his family and they get to the the
support and the help that they need in
2017 Matt was fired from the Today Show
after allegations of sexual misconduct
since then Matt's kept a relatively low
profile and his former Today Show
colleagues have told ZT this
I think he's his heart and his focus is
on his family you know he's sort of
reconnecting with his family and taking
over al roker most recently had this to
say husband I think almost two years
since Matt exited the Today Show how is
he doing I know you guys are good
friends oh yeah I'm sure he's doing well
we just you know I don't I don't really
talk about that that much but we wish
him well
[Music]